another attack has happened in a village
in the eastern Democratic Republic of
Congo people in the town of Beni are
preparing once more to bury loved ones
villages here say armed men ambushed
them with machetes and Gans security
forces blamed the allied democratic
forces or ADF a rebel group in the area
with roots in Uganda its fighters are
accused of killing at least 5,000
Congolese in the last few years and more
than a hundred in the past week they
were dressed in the same uniform as our
army they killed my husband in our
kitchen when I first heard gunshots I
ran outside but I met them and they told
me to get back inside many homes have
been deserted people are too afraid to
go back their attacks are frequent and
happening as a Congolese army and one of
the largest UN peacekeeping missions in
the world when new schoo are carrying
out an offensive against a rebel group
those forces are now working with a
local militia called mai-mai to help
defeat the ADF here the group shows us
their camp and arms and equipment they
say they've captured from an ADF base
deep in the forest
this is our country they will not allow
a foreign rebel group to terrorize our
people we will continue to fight them
those who are supporting them African
leaders are discussing how armed
violence can be stopped in Africa and
not just in this country the Sahel
region has been infiltrated by groups
allied to ISIL and al-qaida hundreds of
people have been killed and millions
displaced in the lake Chad basin African
forces are fighting Boko Haram
insurgents then there's conflict in the
Central African Republic Somalia South
Sudan a little list goes on impunity and
lack of accountability for perpetrators
of human rights violations in the
context of conflicts and some of which
actually rise to crimes under
international law including war crimes
and crimes against humanity
this lack of impurity this lack of
accountability the impunity for
perpetrators is part of these reasons
why there is a cycle of violence across
the
in Ethiopia many kilometers away from
Benny the heads of state are gathered
for a conference labeled silence in the
gans in 2020 and beyond is an ambitious
logon many here are oblivious of that
meeting and what if anything it can
achieve but like millions of others
living in conflict areas across the
continent they say they just wanted to
live in safety catherine saw a
al-jazeera